One week before Christmas, the Target store on Chicago's West Side. Middle of the day. People are rolling shopping carts full of toys and games through the aisles. Teenagers and single people. Parents from every income. And I don't really understand this, but if you talk to them, this incredibly diverse group, there's one question that always seems to get exactly the same answer.
圣诞节前一周，芝加哥西区的塔吉特（Target）百货。正值中午。人们推着装满玩具和游戏的购物车穿过过道。有青少年，也有单身人士。有各种收入水平的家长。我不太理解这一点，但如果你和他们交流，这群极其多元化的人，总有一个问题似乎能得到完全相同的答案。
Of all these things that you have in this basket, what do you think is the most likely to get returned?
在你的篮子里所有这些东西中，你认为最有可能被退货的是什么？
Actually, none of it.
说实话，什么都不会。
Not my stuff.
不会是我的东西。
No. I'd say, no, not mine.
不会。我会说，不，不是我的。
Well, actually, I'm not worried at all. Actually, I did a pretty good job.
嗯，事实上，我一点也不担心。其实我挑得挺好的。
The majority of the the stuff that I'm buying is really for my kids. So they definitely ain't going to be returning anything. So, not my stuff.
我买的大部分东西其实都是给孩子们的。所以他们肯定不会退回任何东西。所以，不会是我的东西。
2: I made a list of what I was getting everyone. And I'm pretty confident in it.
我列了一张清单，记下了给每个人的礼物。我对它很有信心。
When I report their bravado, their confidence, to the store manager Lee Crumb, this is his response.
当我向店经理李·克拉姆（Lee Crumb）汇报他们的这种自信时，这是他的回应。
[LAUGHTER] Well, the day after Christmas is the busiest day in refunds. So I don't know how true that statement is, nobody ever returns my gifts. Of course, everybody has sunglasses and rubber noses on that day when they're returning stuff so nobody sees them. It's really funny when the media's here the day after Christmas and they're filming the return center. Everybody's kind of like--
[笑声] 嗯，圣诞节后的第二天是退货最忙碌的一天。所以我不知道那个说法有多真实，从来没有人退回过我的礼物。当然，那天每个人在退货时都戴着墨镜和橡胶鼻子，这样就没人认出他们了。当媒体在圣诞节后第二天来到这里拍摄退货中心时，真的很有趣。每个人都像……
He hides his face behind his arm.
他用手臂遮住了脸。
Nobody wants their picture taken.
没人想被拍照。
Like criminals.
像罪犯一样。
If you haven't had at least one drama, one stumper, one gift that has been so difficult to figure out this year that you want to cry, then you are a very unusual person leading a very charmed life, my friend. And as proof, we offer you three stories today of Christmas and Christmas presents. From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our show in three gift-wrapped little acts for you today, all tied up pretty with a bow. Act one, Make a Joyful Noise Unto Your Mom, in which two sons try, once and for all, to give their mother a gift that she will actually enjoy. Act two, A Christmas Memory. In that act, Mr. Truman Capote, recorded in 1959, sounding eerily reminiscent of our own David Sedaris. Act three, Secret Santa. A Very, Very Secret Santa. Stay with us.
如果你今年没遇到过至少一件戏剧性的事、一个难题，或者一份让你难到想哭的礼物，那你真的是一个非常不寻常的人，过着非常幸运的生活，我的朋友。作为证明，今天我们要带给大家三个关于圣诞节和圣诞礼物的故事。这是来自WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们的节目分为三个用礼物包装的小片段，都系着漂亮的蝴蝶结。第一幕，《为你的母亲唱响快乐的颂歌》，两个儿子试图为母亲献上一份她真正喜欢的礼物。第二幕，《圣诞记忆》。在这一幕中，杜鲁门·卡波特（Truman Capote）于1959年录制的声音，让人不禁想起我们的戴维·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）。第三幕，《秘密圣诞老人》。一个非常、非常秘密的圣诞老人。请继续收听。
Act one, Make a Joyful Noise Unto Your Mom. There was one other thing that everyone at the Target store I talked to agreed on. And that is that parents are usually the hardest people to shop for. They have everything already, they want nothing, they're used to doing the giving themselves. In Toronto, Ian Brown has had it.
第一幕，《为你的母亲唱响快乐的颂歌》。我在塔吉特百货采访的每个人对另一件事达成了一致。那就是家长通常是最难挑选礼物的人。他们什么都已经有了，什么都不想要，而且他们自己习惯了给予。在多伦多，伊恩·布朗（Ian Brown）受够了。
I know, I know. Deck the halls with bows of holly, 'tis the season to be jolly. Unfortunately, I keep having a certain conversation at this time of year with my 88 year old mother.
我知道，我知道。“用冬青枝装饰大厅，这是欢乐的季节。”不幸的是，每年这个时候，我都要和88岁的母亲进行某种特定的对话。
For a Christmas present, would you like a new pressure cooker?
作为圣诞礼物，你想要个新的高压锅吗？
No, no. I've got a pressure cooker.
不，不。我有高压锅了。
What about a sweater?
那毛衣怎么样？
I've got at least 20 sweaters.
我至少有20件毛衣了。
What about some jewelry?
首饰怎么样？
I have more jewelry than I shall never wear. I don't like jewelry.
我的首饰多到这辈子都戴不完。我不喜欢首饰。
The whole spirit of Christmas is gone. I hate Christmas. Do you know that more people commit suicide at Christmas than any other time of the year?
圣诞节的精神全没了。我讨厌圣诞节。你知道圣诞节自杀的人比一年中任何时候都多吗？
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
Well, that's the truth.
嗯，那是事实。
I don't have this problem with everyone. I like to think I'm actually quite good at giving gifts. I am. I put a lot of effort into it. I remember what so and so said, or he or she wanted last October. I write it down in a notebook. I buy things my chosen recipients will like but wouldn't buy for themselves. But with my mother, all bets are off. She's what's known as hard to buy for. I'm not sure why. There are a million possible reasons. Maybe it's generational, all those depression raised mothers not wanting to be dependent on the kindness of others. Maybe it's a power play. As long as she doesn't like what you give her, you remain properly beholden.
我跟其他人没这个问题。我喜欢认为自己其实很会送礼。我真的很会。我付出了很多努力。我会记住某人去年十月说过的话，或者他想要什么。我把它记在笔记本里。我买那些收礼人会喜欢但自己又不会买的东西。但对于我母亲，一切都说不准。她就是那种所谓的“难买”的人。我不确定为什么。可能有上百万个原因。也许是代沟，那些在大萧条时期长大的母亲们不想依赖别人的善意。也许这是一种权力博弈。只要她不喜欢你给的东西，你就会一直亏欠她。
I realize a lot of mothers are like this. But my mother is an especially hard case. She might say in October, this Christmas, all I want is a tablecloth. Then, when she unwraps said tablecloth Christmas day, she'll look at it, without even taking it out of the package, say, "very nice," and roll her eyes as if no one can see her. Then when you point out that she said she wanted a tablecloth, she'll say matter of factly, "I never said anything of the sort."
我知道很多母亲都是这样。但我母亲是个特别难对付的案例。她可能会在十月份说，这个圣诞节，我只想要一块桌布。然后，当她在圣诞节那天拆开那块桌布时，她会看着它，甚至不把它从包装里拿出来，就说“真不错”，然后翻个白眼，好像没人看到一样。然后当你指出这是她想要的桌布时，她会一本正经地说：“我从来没说过这种话。”
And if, by some miracle, she manages not to totally despise what you've given her, you're still not off the hook. Because then she likes the gift too much and feels embarrassed. My brother and I long ago decided we'd buy one gift between us. That way, at least you split the pain. We bought her a fur coat. She opened the box, sat there with her hands in the fur, and started to cry. "This is too much," she said, through her tears in a strangled voice, then ran upstairs and locked herself in her bedroom for four hours on Christmas day.
如果奇迹发生了，她设法没有完全蔑视你给的东西，你还没脱身。因为那样她会觉得礼物太好而感到尴尬。我哥哥和我很久以前决定合买一份礼物。这样至少可以分摊痛苦。我们给她买了一件皮大衣。她打开盒子，双手放在皮草上，开始哭泣。“这太贵重了，”她哽咽着说，然后跑上楼，在圣诞节那天把自己关在卧室里四个小时。
The last thing my brother-- his name is Tim-- bought my mother-- that she liked, that is-- was a wooden napkin ring. It was hand painted, with flowers. Very pretty. That was 40 years ago. He was six years old. It cost him a nickel at a fair. Sometimes I think the whole gift giving experience has scarred him for life.
我哥哥——他叫蒂姆（Tim）——最后一次买给我母亲的（她喜欢的）礼物是一个木制餐巾环。上面有手绘的花朵。非常漂亮。那是40年前的事了。他当时六岁。在集市上花了他一个镍币。有时我觉得整个送礼的经历给他留下了终身的心理阴影。
I heard-- I don't know who told me, but-- you're not giving gifts this year, right? You, yourself.
我听说——我不知道是谁告诉我的，但——你今年不打算送礼了，对吧？你自己。
I'm not giving gifts, except to children. I think that giving gifts to parents in this sort of desperate search for approval, you know.
我不打算送礼了，除了给小孩子。我认为给父母送礼是一种绝望的认可寻求，你知道的。
Is that what you think it's for?
你觉得这是为了这个？
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Really?
真的吗？
Absolutely. Yeah.
绝对是。是的。
You think we're seeking approval?
你觉得我们在寻求认可？
Yes.
是的。
It's a bit late.
那有点晚了。
I mean, and her disdain for gifts, when you give them, is pretty bad, don't you think? Here, Mom. Here's a beautiful new spring hat. I hate this. What sort of a gift--
我的意思是，当你送她礼物时，她那种不屑一顾的态度很糟糕，你不觉得吗？给你，妈。这是一顶漂亮的春季新帽。我讨厌这个。这是什么破礼物——
Where do you expect me to wear that?
你指望我戴着它去哪？
It's really horrible.
真是太糟糕了。
But do you think she's a good gift giver? I mean, here we are, sort of trying to get--
但你觉得她是一个好的送礼者吗？我的意思是，我们在这里，试图去——
Yes, I think she is. She is a very good gifter, very generous. I mean, she's almost blind. She's got cataracts, she's knitting socks for people. I told her I wanted a pair of argyle socks last year, she made a pair. That's very difficult, argyle socks.
是的，我觉得她是。她是一个非常好的送礼人，非常慷慨。我的意思是，她几乎失明了。她有白内障，但她还在为别人织袜子。我去年告诉她我想要一双菱形格纹的袜子，她真的织了一双。那很难，菱形格纹的袜子。
You asked her for argyle socks?
你向她要菱形格纹袜子？
Yeah. Well, I like the hand-knit socks.
是的。嗯，我喜欢手工织的袜子。
I like the hand-knit socks. Well, I'm sure you do.
我喜欢手工织的袜子。好吧，我肯定你喜欢。
That was on the sixth of December, and still, we had no clue what to give Mom for Christmas this year. But then, I had this idea. A potentially brilliant idea. Maybe, after all this time, the perfect Christmas present.
那是12月6日，我们依然不知道今年圣诞节该送妈妈什么。但后来，我有了个主意。一个可能有创意的点子。也许，在这么久之后，完美的圣诞礼物终于找到了。
When my brother and I were kids in school, we sang in the choir. Tim was talented. He was a treble and then a tenor. I was a tenor, then a bass. And when we came home from school for the holidays, and were doing the dishes after Christmas dinner, say, we'd sing Christmas carols. We get my sisters, Maude and Daisy, to sing the melodies. And we'd sing the harmonies.
我和哥哥小时候在学校唱诗班唱歌。蒂姆很有天赋。他先是唱高音，后来是男高音。我是男高音，后来是低音。当我们回家过节时，比如圣诞晚宴后洗碗的时候，我们会唱圣诞颂歌。我们会让姐妹们，莫德（Maude）和黛西（Daisy），唱主旋律。我们唱和声。
We liked doing it. Better still, our mother liked it. She started to ask us to do it every time we came home. We were pretty good, too. Our choir had even cut a record, which my mother owned about 17 copies of and played all the time.
我们喜欢这样做。更好的是，我们母亲喜欢。每次我们回家她都要求我们唱。我们唱得也挺好。我们的唱诗班甚至出过唱片，我母亲大约有17张，总是播放。
And that's what gave me the idea. Instead of buying her something she'll hate, my brother and I will drive out to our parents' place-- something neither of us does enough-- and, as grown men, we will sing her some carols in harmony. The sheer sound of our soaring voices will, as they say in the Anglican hymn book, lift up her heart and transport her back to those days when we were her boys.
就是这个给了我灵感。与其买她会讨厌的东西，不如我和哥哥开车去父母家——这是我们俩平时做不够的事——作为成年男人，我们为她唱几首和声颂歌。正如圣公会赞美诗集里所说，我们嘹亮声音的纯粹力量会鼓舞她的心，带她回到那些我们还是她心爱小男孩的日子。
Neither my brother or I have sung in a choir in years. But we harmonize now and then. We even make harmonies up. And I've always been very impressed.
我和哥哥已经多年没在唱诗班唱歌了。但我们偶尔会和声。我们甚至会即兴创作和声。我一直印象很深。
And how do you think the singing is going to sound?
你觉得唱出来会是什么效果？
I think that it might be fairly putrid.
我觉得可能会相当糟糕。
Putrid?
糟糕？
Yeah.
是的。
Really? I've had this impression that we sound great singing the harmonies.
真的吗？我一直觉得我们唱和声时声音很棒。
Yeah.
是的。
[SINGING - "O LITTLE TOWN OF BETHLEHEM"]
[演唱 - 《小小伯利恒》]
I hear my brother, and I think, it's all up to me.
我听见我哥哥的声音，心想，全靠我了。
[SINGING - "O LITTLE TOWN OF BETHLEHEM"]
[演唱 - 《小小伯利恒》]
Oh my God. That is hideous.
天哪。真是太恐怖了。
Was it hideous? Does it sound bad?
很恐怖吗？听起来很糟糕？
Bad? We sounded like people who'd been lost in the woods. But how could we fix it? 24 hour emergency carol-singing repair isn't a service listed in the Yellow Pages where I live. So I did the only thing I could think of. I called Eric Hanbury. Hanbury had been at boarding school with my brother and me. He was in the choir, too. He was an eccentric character even then. Very serious and strict, almost terrifying. He knew how to play the organ, for starters. And that was an unusual skill for a teenager to have back in the days when Led Zeppelin were releasing their first album. Hanbury's musical taste stopped at Gershwin and favored Bach. Plus, he was six foot two, even then, and had full mutton chop sideburns at the age of 12. I hadn't seen him in nearly 35 years.
糟糕？我们听起来像是在森林里迷路的人。但我们怎么才能补救呢？我住的地方黄页里没有“24小时紧急颂歌修复服务”。所以我只能想到唯一的办法。我给埃里克·汉伯里（Eric Hanbury）打了电话。汉伯里和我哥哥及我以前是寄宿学校的同学。他也在唱诗班。那时他就是个古怪的角色。非常严肃和死板，甚至有点吓人。首先，他会弹管风琴。这在齐柏林飞艇（Led Zeppelin）发行第一张专辑的年代，对于青少年来说是一种罕见的技能。汉伯里的音乐品味止步于格什温（Gershwin），且偏爱巴赫。况且，他当时身高就有6英尺2英寸，12岁时就留着浓密的连鬓胡子。我有快35年没见过他了。
Hello?
喂？
Eric Hanbury?
埃里克·汉伯里？
Yeah, Ian. Come up, 1204.
对，伊恩。上来吧，1204室。
All right.
好的。
But by 10:30 on Saturday morning, the very day we're to sing for our mother, we are in Eric Hanbury's two bedroom apartment on the 16th floor of a high rise in the Northwest end of the city. The spare bedroom-- the one we're all packed into-- is mostly taken up by a church organ the size of a Ford Taurus, complete with foot pedals.
到了周六上午10:30，也就是我们要为母亲唱歌的那天，我们在埃里克·汉伯里位于城市西北区一栋高层建筑16楼的两居室公寓里。空闲的卧室——我们都挤在里面——大部分空间被一台像福特金牛座（Ford Taurus）汽车那么大的教堂管风琴占据了，上面还有踏板。
Now.
开始。
[SINGING - "JOY TO THE WORLD"]
[演唱 - 《普世欢腾》]
Terrible. Let's do verse three. And I'll just play really loudly.
太烂了。我们唱第三段吧。我会弹得响一点。
It doesn't take long for Eric to lose hope, which is more depressing than I anticipated.
埃里克没花多长时间就失去了希望，这比我预想的更令人沮丧。
[SINGING - "O LITTLE TOWN OF BETHLEHEM"]
[演唱 - 《小小伯利恒》]
No, no, no. How silently, how silently means that you don't yell.
不，不，不。“悄悄地，悄悄地”意味着你不要大喊大叫。
[SINGING - "O LITTLE TOWN OF BETHLEHEM"]
[演唱 - 《小小伯利恒》]
We're so desperate, we consult three other experts. The only helpful advice we get is from the greatest of them, John Tuttle, the choir master at Saint Thomas's Anglican Church, which everyone around here knows is one of the two or three best choirs in the city. He's famous for his high standards, his hours of practice. He gives us a few phrasing tips to make it sound like we actually mean the words we're singing.
我们太绝望了，咨询了其他三位专家。我们得到的唯一有帮助的建议来自最伟大的那一位，约翰·塔特尔（John Tuttle），圣托马斯圣公会教堂的唱诗班指挥，大家都知道那是城里最好的一两个唱诗班之一。他以高标准和漫长的排练时间而闻名。他给了我们一些措辞建议，让我们听起来像是真的在用心唱歌。
You wouldn't say, and heaven, and heaven, and nature sing. And heaven, and heaven, and nature sing.
你不会唱“and heaven, and heaven, and nature sing”。应该是“And heaven and nature sing”。
[SINGING - "JOY TO THE WORLD"]
[演唱 - 《普世欢腾》]
And it works.
奏效了。
[SINGING - "JOY TO THE WORLD"]
[演唱 - 《普世欢腾》]
Much better.
好多了。
Yeah, that's better.
是的，好多了。
But it doesn't last, because just as this thin ray of hope peeps forth, just as we feel good for the first time all day, we stopped for lunch at a restaurant, and my brother checks his cell phone for messages. And there is one from my father. He sounds pretty frosty. And this is when I find out that my brother has had a fight with my mother. They haven't spoken in three weeks, which is why my father is making the call for my mother. I mean, it's really bad. You can hear my mother in the background telling my old man what to say.
但好景不长，就在这一线希望刚刚显露，就在我们整天里第一次感到高兴时，我们在一家餐馆停下来吃午饭，我哥哥查了一下手机里的留言。有一条是我父亲打来的。他听起来很冷漠。这时我才知道我哥哥和我母亲吵架了。他们已经三个星期没说话了，这就是为什么我父亲代替我母亲给我打电话。我的意思是，真的很严重。我能听到我母亲在背景里告诉老头子该说什么。
"Timmy," my dad says. And I can hear the edge of displeasure in his voice. "I understand you're coming out here. We have to go out in 15 minutes. We don't know where you are, so there is no use you coming out. We're not going to be here. We're not going to wait around for Ian. And incidentally, incidentally, we will not be coming to your Christmas dinner party next Sunday night." And then he hangs up. He doesn't even bother to say goodbye, but then, he never does.
“蒂米（Timmy），”我爸说。我能听到他声音里带着不满。 “我知道你要过来。我们15分钟后就要出门。我们不知道你在哪，所以你来也没用。我们不在家。我们不会等伊恩。顺便说一句，我们下周日不会去参加你的圣诞晚宴了。” 然后他就挂了。他连再见都没说，不过他从来不说。
It's a 40 minute drive to my parents'. They live in a small house in the country beside a river. All the way out, we practice trying to hone the edge we picked up from John Tuttle.
开车去我父母家要40分钟。他们住在乡下一个河边的小房子里。一路上，我们都在练习磨练从约翰·塔特尔那里学来的技巧。
(INTERVIEWER) IAN BROWN: [SINGING] There is no gas station over here.
（采访者）伊恩·布朗：[唱歌] 这里没有加油站。
[SINGING] I apologize. You must turn left--
[唱歌] 我道歉。你必须左转——
(INTERVIEWER) IAN BROWN: --[SINGING] to get into it. Would let me go ahead? Thank you very much. What a nice guy.
（采访者）伊恩·布朗：——[唱歌] 才能进去。能让我先过去吗？非常感谢。真是个好人。
We finally pull up to my parents' house. It's cold outside, around zero Fahrenheit. It's one of those filing cabinet gray Canadian days that feels colder than it would if there was snow on the ground. We walk up to the front door.
我们终于开到了父母家。外面很冷，华氏零度左右。那是那种典型的加拿大灰色日子，比有雪的时候感觉更冷。我们走到前门。
(INTERVIEWER) IAN BROWN: OK, wait. Where's the doorbell?
（采访者）伊恩·布朗：好的，等等。门铃在哪？
There is no doorbell. They'll know we're here. They'll know we're here.
没有门铃。他们会知道我们来了。他们会知道的。
How will they know? OK. Ready? Wait. OK. Ready?
他们怎么会知道？好了。准备好了吗？等等。好的。准备好了吗？
[SINGING - "JOY TO THE WORLD"]
[演唱 - 《普世欢腾》]
As we sang, I thought to myself, so, it has come to this. The bottom of the barrel. Two grown men in their 40s, standing outside in the sub-freezing winter, singing to a closed door. Begging, essentially.
我们唱歌的时候，心里想，好吧，竟然到了这一步。沦落到这种地步。两个40多岁的成年男人，站在零下的冬天里，对着一扇紧闭的门唱歌。本质上就是在乞求。
Thank you very much. That was very nice.
非常感谢。那非常好听。
Shall we come in? Can we come in? It's freezing outside. Can we come in?
我们能进去吗？能进去吗？外面冷极了。我们可以进去吗？
Don't breathe your germs on me.
别把你的细菌传给我。
What's that?
你说什么？
Don't bring your germs in here.
别把你的细菌带到这来。
Don't bring your germs in here. That's nice. All right, here we go.
别把细菌带进屋。真好。好吧，开始吧。
[SINGING - "O LITTLE TOWN OF BETHLEHEM"]
[演唱 - 《小小伯利恒》]
My mother moves from the doorway to a dining room chair and sits down. She's looking at the floor, but I think she's ever so slightly crying. My brother can see it, too. I don't want her to cry. But then, it doesn't seem to last.
母亲从门口走到餐厅的椅子上坐下。她看着地板，但我认为她正微微流泪。我哥哥也看到了。我不想让她哭。但后来，那似乎没有持续太久。
This is your Christmas present.
这是你的圣诞礼物。
Thank you very much. That was very nice. Reminded me of when you were nice boys who went to school and sang in the choir.
非常感谢。那非常好听。让我想起了你们小时候当乖孩子在唱诗班唱歌的时候。
And? You're implying that we're not like that anymore?
然后呢？你是暗示我们现在不一样了？
I don't know. You don't even come to see me unless you want something, so. Do you want a cup of tea?
我不知道。除非你们有事求我，否则你们根本不来看我。你们要喝杯茶吗？
(INTERVIEWER) IAN BROWN: Yes, that would be nice. Yes, a cup of tea.
（采访者）伊恩·布朗：是的，那太好了。是的，一杯茶。
We go into the kitchen.
我们走进厨房。
(INTERVIEWER) IAN BROWN: So how does that compare with other presents we've given you?
（采访者）伊恩·布朗：那跟你以前收到过的礼物比起来怎么样？
Very nice. Very exceptional. Thank you very much.
非常好。非常独特。真的非常感谢。
What's the best present we've ever given you?
我们给过你的最好的礼物是什么？
I'd ask for help.
我会寻求帮助。
(INTERVIEWER) IAN BROWN: What? Help?
（采访者）伊恩·布朗：什么？帮助？
Do you know what I would really like? I would like you all to come in the spring, help me clean up the garden, help me clean up the house, re-paper the house. That would be lovely.
你知道我真的想要什么吗？我希望你们春天都能来，帮我打扫花园，帮我打扫房子，给房子重新贴墙纸。那会很美妙。
Re-paper the house?
给房子重新贴墙纸？
Re-paper.
重新贴墙纸。
(SUBJECT) TIM BROWN: Re-paper the living room?
（受访者）蒂姆·布朗：重贴客厅？
The living room, the bath, anywhere.
客厅，浴室，哪里都行。
So this has been my problem, gift-wise, all along. Here I was trying to satisfy my mother with some $60 blouse, when what she really wanted was an $8,000 wallpapering job. I am so distracted by this revelation that I don't notice her trying to reverse the gift giving polarity in her favor. Even before the carol is over-- before we finish giving her our gift-- she starts reciprocating, giving us items she has harvested from all over the house. Not just our Christmas presents-- two envelopes of cash-- but other stuff. A calendar of coupons, half a round of Swiss cheese. And what's this? A beautiful cashmere scarf. The same one I had given to my brother at Christmas last year.
这就是我一直以来的送礼问题。我一直试图用一件60美元的衬衫来满足母亲，而她真正想要的是一份8000美元的墙纸工程。我被这个揭示震惊到忽略了她试图把送礼关系反转以对自己有利。甚至在颂歌结束前——在我们完成礼物之前——她就开始回礼了，把她从屋里收集来的东西给我们。不仅仅是我们的圣诞礼物——两个装现金的信封——还有其他东西。一本优惠券日历，半块瑞士奶酪。还有这是什么？一条漂亮的羊绒围巾。就是去年圣诞节我送给我哥哥的那条。
Oh my God. Where did you get that?
天哪。你从哪弄来的？
It's been up in the cupboard.
它一直放在柜子里。
For how long? That's a cashmere scarf. I gave you that for Christmas last year. And you left it here? You haven't even-- why do I bother?
放了多久？这是羊绒围巾。我去年圣诞节送给你的。你就把它落在这了？你甚至还没……我为什么要费这个劲？
So much for my famous gift giving abilities. No one in my family appreciates my effort. And this was true, it suddenly became clear, of this gift of song as well.
我那著名的送礼能力就算了吧。我家没人欣赏我的努力。而且我突然意识到，这唱歌的礼物也一样。
Shall we do one more?
我们要再唱一首吗？
Yeah.
好吧。
No, I haven't got time.
不，我没时间。
You hear that? She hasn't got time.
你听到了吗？她没时间。
Go in there and do it.
进去唱吧。
We're doing it for you.
我们是在为你唱。
It's your Christmas present.
这是你的圣诞礼物。
That's enough. You've done enough.
够了。你们已经做得够多了。
You don't want to hear "Blest Are The Pure in Heart"?
你不想听《纯洁者蒙福》吗？
No. She was not interested in "The Pure In Heart." And you know why? Because she was about to miss her favorite TV program. She was giving us the bum's rush.
不想。她对《纯洁者蒙福》不感兴趣。你知道为什么吗？因为她快错过她最喜欢的电视节目了。她在赶我们走。
Very nice. Thank you both very much indeed.
非常好。真的非常感谢你们俩。
You're missing your TV program.
你要错过电视节目了。
Lovely seeing you.
很高兴见到你们。
Yes, lovely to see you. What's the name of the program?
是的，很高兴见到你们。那节目叫什么名字？
Pie in the Sky.
《空中馅饼》（Pie in the Sky）。
Pie in the Sky. Goodbye. See you, Dad. Goodbye, Ma. Love you.
《空中馅饼》。再见。再见，爸。再见，妈。爱你们。
So we drove the 40 miles right back to the city. We devoted a whole day to giving our mother the perfect gift, only to get kicked out of her house after 26 minutes in favor of Pie in the Sky, an English TV series about a country detective who makes the best steak and kidney pie in the world. Actually, my mother used to make excellent steak and kidney pie herself, and give it away as Christmas presents. Of course, no Christmas story is complete without a grand, final realization. And on the way home, I had mine.
所以我们开了40英里路直接回到了城里。我们花了一整天的时间给母亲送上完美的礼物，结果却在26分钟后被赶出了家门，因为她要看《空中馅饼》，一部关于一个会做世界上最好的牛排腰子饼的乡村侦探的英国电视连续剧。其实，我母亲以前自己也做极好的牛排腰子饼，还会当作圣诞礼物送人。当然，没有一个圣诞故事是缺少宏大最终感悟的。在回家的路上，我有了自己的感悟。
We'd been going about it all wrong. We'd been trying to find the perfect Christmas present. But the perfect gift was a terrible idea, because the perfect gift upsets the delicate truce of failure and imperfection that holds every family together like a trussed bridge. You move one timber, the whole thing can come crashing down. Whereas if you leave that rickety old span as it has always been-- with a little too much need over here, and a little too much eagerness to please over there, all offset by an overhang of standoffishness-- then everyone is happy.
我们一直以来都错了。我们一直试图寻找完美的圣诞礼物。但完美礼物是个糟糕的主意，因为完美礼物会打破那种维系每个家庭的脆弱平衡——那种失败和缺陷的平衡，就像一个桁架桥。你移动一根梁，整个东西可能就会崩塌。而如果你保持那个破旧的结构，像它一直以来那样——这里有一点太多的需求，那里有一点太多的讨好，再由某种超脱来抵消——那么每个人都很快乐。
The secret, obviously, is to give an imperfect gift, that lavishes enough attention on your old mom that she knows you still care, but that's also fundamentally flawed, so that no one goes home feeling indebted or beholden or lonely. Instead, they can go home reassured. Nothing changes. And that's a Christmas present even a mother could love.
显然，秘诀在于送出一份不完美的礼物，既对老妈投入足够的关注，让她知道你还关心她，但它本质上又是有缺陷的，这样没人会带着亏欠、受缚或孤独的感觉回家。相反，他们可以带着宽慰回家。一切都没变。那是连母亲都能爱的圣诞礼物。
Ian Brown, normally broadcast on the CBC.
伊恩·布朗，通常在加拿大广播公司（CBC）播出。
Act Two, A Christmas Memory. We heard about this next recording because the in-laws of one of our producers play it every Christmas when the family gets together. And every Christmas they all cry. It's Truman Capote's story, "A Christmas Memory," about his own childhood growing up in rural Alabama in the 1920s and '30s. This is an abridged version of the story, shortened a bit for the radio.
第二幕，《圣诞记忆》。我们听说这个录音，是因为我们一位制片人的姻亲每年圣诞节聚会时都会放它。而且每年圣诞节他们都会哭。这是杜鲁门·卡波特的短篇小说《圣诞记忆》，讲述了他20世纪20和30年代在亚拉巴马州农村成长的童年。这是该故事的删节版，为了广播稍微压缩了一下。
Imagine a morning in late November. A coming of winter morning more than 20 years ago. A woman with shorn white hair is standing at the kitchen window. "Oh my," she exclaims, her breath smoking the window pane. "It's fruitcake weather." The person to whom she is speaking is myself. I am seven. She is sixty something. We are cousins, very distant ones, and we have lived together, well, as long as I can remember. Other people inhabit the house, relatives. And though they have power over us and frequently make us cry, we are not, on the whole, too much aware of them. We are each other's best friend. She calls me Buddy, in memory of a boy who was formerly her best friend. The other Buddy died in the 1880s when she was still a child. She is still a child.
想象一个11月下旬的早晨。一个20多年前冬天的早晨。一位剪着短白发的女性正站在厨房窗前。“天哪，”她感叹道，呼吸在玻璃窗上留下了烟雾。 “这是做水果蛋糕的天气。” 她对话的对象是我。我七岁。她六十多岁。我们是堂表亲，关系非常疏远，但我们住在一起，嗯，只要我有记忆以来就是这样。家里还住着其他人，亲戚们。虽然他们对我们有权势，经常让我们哭泣，但总体来说，我们并没有太在意他们。我们是彼此最好的朋友。她叫我“巴迪”（Buddy），是为了纪念以前她最好的朋友。另一个巴迪在19世纪80年代她还是个孩子时就去世了。她至今仍像个孩子。
"I knew it before I got out of bed," she says, turning away from the window with a purposeful excitement in her eyes. "Help me find my hat. We have 30 cakes to bake." In addition to never having seen a movie, she has never eaten in a restaurant, traveled more than five miles from home, received or sent a telegram, read anything except funny papers and the Bible, worn cosmetics, cursed, wished someone harm, told a lie on purpose, let a hungry dog go hungry. Of the ingredients that go into our fruitcakes, whiskey is the most expensive, as well as the hardest to obtain. State laws forbid its sale. But everybody knows you can buy a bottle from Mr. Haha Jones.
“我还没起床就感觉到了，”她说，带着一种有目的的兴奋从窗边转过身。“帮我找我的帽子。我们得烤30个蛋糕。” 除了没看过电影，她没在餐馆吃过饭，没去过离家五英里远的地方，没收发过电报，除了读过滑稽报纸和圣经外什么都没读过，没化过妆，没骂过人，没愿别人受害，没故意撒过谎，没让饥饿的狗挨过饿。在我们水果蛋糕的原料中，威士忌是最贵的，也是最难弄到的。州法律禁止销售。但大家都知道你可以从哈哈·琼斯（Haha Jones）先生那里买到一瓶。
And the next day, having completed our more prosaic shopping, we set out for Mr. Haha's business address. A sinful, to quote public opinion, fish fry and dancing cafe down by the river. We've been there before, and on the same errand. But in previous years, our dealings have been with Haha's wife, an iodine-dark Indian woman with brassy, peroxided hair and a dead tired disposition. Actually, we've never laid eyes on her husband, but we've heard that he's an Indian, too, a giant with razor scars across his cheeks. They call him Haha because he's so gloomy, a man who never laughs.
第二天，完成更琐碎的购物后，我们出发前往哈哈先生的营业地址。一个用大众说法叫“罪恶”的炸鱼跳舞咖啡馆，就在河边。我们以前来过，也是为了同样的差事。但往年我们都是和哈哈的妻子打交道，一个碘色深褐皮肤、头发漂成劣质黄色的印第安女人，神情总是厌世疲惫。其实我们从来没见过她丈夫，但听说他也是印第安人，是个脸上有剃刀疤痕的巨人。他们叫他“哈哈”，因为他太阴郁了，是个从不笑的人。
As we approach his cafe-- a large log cabin festooned inside and out with chains of garish, gay naked light bulbs, and standing by the river's muddy edge under the shade of river trees, where moss drifts through the branches like gray mist-- our steps slow down. Even Queenie stops prancing and sticks close by. People have been murdered in Haha's cafe, cut to pieces, hit on the head. There's a case coming up in court next month. I knock at the door, Queenie barks, my friend calls, "Mrs. Haha, ma'am? Anyone to home?"
当我们接近他的咖啡馆——一个内外挂满了俗气、耀眼裸露电灯泡链的大圆木小屋，矗立在河边泥泞边缘，在遮蔽河岸树木的阴影下，青苔像灰色薄雾般漂浮在树枝间——我们的脚步放慢了。连小狗奎尼（Queenie）也停止了跳跃，紧贴着我们。有人在哈哈的咖啡馆被谋杀过，被剁碎，被击打头部。下个月法庭有个案子要审。我敲了敲门，奎尼吠叫，我朋友喊道：“哈哈太太，女士？有人在家吗？”
Footsteps. The door opens. Our hearts overturn. It's Mr. Haha Jones himself, and he is a giant, he does have scars, he doesn't smile. No, he glowers at us through Satan-tilted eyes and demands to know, "What you want with Haha?" For a moment, we are too paralyzed to tell. Presently, my friend half-finds her voice, a whispery voice at best. If you please, Mr. Haha, we'd like a quart of your finest whiskey.
脚步声。门开了。我们的心都悬起来了。那是哈哈·琼斯先生本人，他确实是个巨人，也确实有疤痕，他也确实没笑。不，他透过撒旦般倾斜的双眼盯着我们，质问：“你们找哈哈想干什么？” 一时间，我们瘫痪到说不出话。不久，我朋友勉强挤出声音，那声音顶多算个耳语。如果不介意的话，哈哈先生，我们想要一夸脱你最好的威士忌。
His eyes tilt more. Would you believe it? Haha is smiling, laughing too. "Which one of you is a drinking man?" "It's for making fruitcakes, Mr. Haha. Cooking." This sobers him. He frowns. "That's no way to waste good whiskey." We pay him with nickels, and dimes, and pennies. Suddenly, jangling the coins in his hand like a fist full of dice, his face softens. "Tell you what," he proposes, pouring the money back into our bead purse, "just send me one of them fruitcakes instead."
他的眼睛斜得更厉害了。你敢相信吗？哈哈在笑，也在大笑。“你们俩谁喝酒？” “这是用来做水果蛋糕的，哈哈先生。烹饪用的。” 这让他冷静下来。他皱起眉头。“那太浪费好威士忌了。” 我们用镍币、硬币和便士付钱。突然，他手里像握着一把骰子般叮当作响，他的脸软化了。“这样吧，”他提议道，把钱倒回我们的珠子小钱包里，“只要送我一个水果蛋糕就行了。”
"Well," my friend remarks on our way home, "there's a lovely man. We'll put an extra cup of raisins in his cake." The black stove, stoked with coal and firewood, glows like a lighted pumpkin. Egg beaters whirl, spoons spin round in bowls of butter and sugar, vanilla sweetens the air, ginger spices it. Melting, nose-tingling odors saturate the kitchen, suffuse the house, drift out to the world on puffs of chimney smoke. In four days, our work is done. 31 cakes, dampened with whiskey, bask on window sills and shelves.
“嗯，”我们在回家的路上评论，“真是个可爱的人。我们要在他蛋糕里多加一杯葡萄干。” 燃着煤和木柴的黑色炉子，闪耀得像一个发光的南瓜。蛋抽飞转，勺子在盛满黄油和糖的碗里旋转，香草使空气变得甜蜜，姜带来了香辛味。融化的、刺激鼻腔的气味充满了厨房，弥漫在房子里，随着烟囱喷出的烟雾飘向世界。四天后，我们的工作完成了。31个蛋糕，被威士忌浸润，在窗台和架子上晾晒。
Who are they for? Friends. Not necessarily neighbor friends. Indeed, the larger share are intended for persons we've met maybe once, perhaps not at all, people who have struck our fancy, like President Roosevelt, like the Reverend and Mrs. J. C. Lucey, Baptist missionaries to Borneo who lectured here last winter. Or the little knife grinder who comes through town twice a year. Or the young Wistons, a California couple whose car, one afternoon, broke down outside the house and who spent a pleasant hour chatting with us on the porch. Young Mr. Wiston snapped our picture, the only one we've ever had taken.
它们是为谁准备的？朋友们。不一定是邻居。事实上，大部分是送给那些我们可能只见过一次，甚至根本没见过的人，那些让我们产生好感的人，比如罗斯福总统，比如在婆罗洲传教的J.C.卢西牧师夫妇，他们去年冬天在这里演讲过。还有那个每年两次路过镇上的磨刀匠。或者年轻的威斯顿（Wistons）夫妇，他们的车有一天下午在我们家门外抛锚，我们在门廊上聊了一个小时。年轻的威斯顿先生拍了我们的照片，那是我们唯一的照片。
Now a new December fig branch grates against the window. The kitchen is empty, the cakes are gone. Yesterday we carted the last of them to the post office, where the cost of stamps turned our purse inside out. We're broke. That rather depresses me, but my friend insists on celebrating with two inches of whisky left in Haha's bottle. Queenie has a spoonful in a bowl of coffee. She likes her coffee chicory-flavored and strong. The rest we divide between a pair of jelly glasses. We're both quite awed at the prospect of drinking straight whiskey. The taste of it brings screwed up expressions and sour shudders. But by and by, we begin to sing, the two of us singing different songs simultaneously. I don't know the words to mine, just, "Come on along, come on along, to the dark-town strutter's ball."
现在一根新的12月无花果枝蹭着窗户。厨房空了，蛋糕都没了。昨天我们把最后一批蛋糕运到了邮局，那里的邮费掏空了我们的钱包。我们身无分文。这让我有点沮丧，但我朋友坚持要用哈哈瓶子里剩下的两英寸威士忌庆祝一下。奎尼在咖啡碗里分到了一勺。她喜欢加了菊苣、口感浓郁的咖啡。剩下的我们平分在两个果冻杯里。我们对于喝纯威士忌的前景都感到敬畏。喝下去的味道让我们表情扭曲、身体酸涩战栗。但不久之后，我们开始唱歌，我们两人同时唱着不同的歌。我不知道我的歌词，只记得，“Come on along, come on along, to the dark-town strutter's ball.”
But I can dance. That's what I mean to be, a tap dancer in the movies. My dancing shadow rollicks on the walls. Our voices rock the chinaware. We giggle, as if unseen hands were tickling us. Queenie rolls on her back, her paws plow the air. Something like a grin stretches her black lips. Inside myself, I feel warm and sparky as those crumbling logs, carefree as the wind in the chimney. My friend waltzes around the stove, the hem of her poor calico skirt pinched between her fingers as though it were a party dress. "Show me the way to go home," she sings, her tennis shoes squeaking on the floor. "Show me the way to go home."
但我会跳舞。那就是我的理想，做电影里的踢踏舞者。我跳舞的影子在墙上欢快地晃动。我们的歌声撼动了瓷器。我们咯咯笑着，好像无形的手在挠我们痒痒。奎尼翻滚着背，爪子在空中刨动。某种类似笑容的东西拉伸了她黑色的嘴唇。内心深处，我感到温暖而充满活力，就像那些崩裂的圆木，像烟囱里的风一样无忧无虑。我朋友绕着炉子跳华尔兹，她那件可怜的印花布裙子的下摆捏在她指间，仿佛那是件礼服。“指引我回家的路，”她唱道，网球鞋在木地板上发出吱吱声。“指引我回家的路。”
Enter two relatives. Very angry. Potent with eyes that scold, tongues that scald. Listen to what they have to say, the words tumbling together into a wrathful tune. "A child of seven, whiskey on his breath. Are you out of your mind? Feeding a child of seven, must be loony. Road to ruination. Remember cousin Kate, Uncle Charlie, Uncle Charlie's brother in law? Shame. Scandal. Humiliation. Pray. Beg the Lord." Queenie sneaks under the stove. My friend gazes at her shoes. Her chin quivers. She lifts her skirt, and blows her nose, and runs to her room.
两个亲戚进来了。非常生气。眼里喷着怒火，舌头带着刻薄。听听他们怎么说，话语汇集成一首愤慨的曲子。“一个七岁的孩子，嘴里有威士忌的味道。你们疯了吗？喂一个七岁孩子喝酒，一定是疯了。走上毁灭之路。记住凯特表姐，查理叔叔，查理叔叔的妹夫？丢人。丑闻。羞辱。祈祷吧。向上帝乞求吧。” 奎尼溜进炉子下面。我朋友盯着她的鞋子。下巴在颤抖。她提起裙子，擤了擤鼻子，跑回了自己的房间。
Long after the town has gone to sleep, and the house is silent except for the chimings of clocks and the sputter of fading fires, she is weeping into a pillow, already as wet as a widow's handkerchief. "Don't cry," I say, sitting at the bottom of her bed and shivering, despite my flannel night gown that smells of last winter's cough syrup. "Don't cry," I beg, teasing her toes, tickling her feet. "You're too old for that." "It's because," she hiccups, "I am too old. Old and funny." "Not funny, fun. More fun than anybody. Listen, if you don't stop crying, you'll be so tired tomorrow we can't go cut a tree."
镇上早已入睡很久之后，房子里除了钟声和渐弱的炉火声外一片寂静，她在枕头上啜泣，那枕头已经湿得像寡妇的手帕。“别哭，”我坐在她床边说，尽管我穿着闻起来像去年冬天止咳糖浆的法兰绒睡袍，但我还是在颤抖。“别哭，”我恳求道，逗弄着她的脚趾，挠着她的脚心。 “你都这么大岁数了还这样。” “这是因为，”她打了个嗝说，“我岁数太大了。又老又滑稽。” “不滑稽，是充满乐趣。比任何人都更有趣。听着，如果你不停止哭泣，明天你就会太累，我们就没法去砍树了。”
She straightens up. Queenie jumps on the bed, where Queenie is not allowed, to lick her cheeks.
她挺直了身子。奎尼跳上床，尽管奎尼是不允许上床的，但还是舔了舔她的脸颊。
"I know where we'll find real pretty trees, Buddy, and holly too, with berries big as your eyes. It's way off in the woods, farther than we've ever been. Papa used to bring us Christmas trees from there and carry them on his shoulder. That's 50 years ago. Well, now I can't wait for morning."
“我知道去哪能找到真正漂亮的树，巴迪，还有冬青树，浆果大得像你的眼睛。它在森林深处，比我们去过的任何地方都远。爸爸以前经常从那里带回圣诞树，扛在肩上。那是50年前的事了。好了，现在我等不及天亮了。”
Morning. Scented acres of holiday trees, prickly-leafed holly, red berries, shiny as Chinese bells. Black crows swoop upon them, screaming. Having stuffed our burlap sacks with enough greenery and crimson to garland a dozen windows, we set about choosing a tree.
清晨。香气扑鼻的节庆树丛，带刺叶子的冬青，像中国铃铛一样红亮闪烁的浆果。乌鸦在它们头上俯冲、尖叫。把粗麻袋塞满足以装饰十几个窗户的绿叶和深红浆果后，我们开始选树。
"It should be," muses my friend, "twice as tall as a boy, so a boy can't steal the star." The one we pick is twice as tall as me. A brave, handsome brute that survives 30 hatchet strokes before it keels with a creaking, rending cry. After weaving and ribboning holly wreaths for all the front windows, our next project is the fashioning of family gifts. Tie dye scarves for the ladies. For the men, a home-brewed lemon, and licorice, and aspirin syrup to be taken at the first symptoms of a cold and after hunting. But when it comes time for making each other's gifts, my friend and I separate to work secretly.
“它应该是，”我朋友沉思道，“比男孩高两倍，这样男孩就偷不走星星。” 我们选的那棵树比我高两倍。一棵勇敢、英俊的“猛兽”，在斧头砍了30下之后，发出一声吱吱嘎嘎的哀鸣倒下了。在为所有前窗编织和绑好冬青花环后，下一个项目是制作家庭礼物。给女士们的扎染围巾。给男士们的，是自制的柠檬、甘草和阿司匹林糖浆，在感冒初起或打猎后服用。但当到了制作彼此礼物的时候，我和我朋友分开秘密工作。
I would like to buy her a pearl handle knife, a radio, a whole pound of chocolate covered cherries. We tasted some once, and she always swears, "I could live on them, Buddy. Lord, yes I could, and that's not taking his name in vain."
我想给她买一把珍珠柄的小刀，一台收音机，一整磅巧克力樱桃。我们尝过一次，她总是发誓：“我能靠那个活下去，巴迪。天哪，是的，我能，而且那不是在亵渎神明。”
Instead, I am building her a kite. She would like to give me a bicycle. She has said so on several million occasions. "If only I could, Buddy. It's bad enough in life to do without something you want. But confound it, what gets my goat is not being able to give somebody something you want them to have. Only one of these days, I will, Buddy. Locate you a bike. Don't ask how. Steal it, maybe."
相反，我正在给她做一个风筝。她本想送我一辆自行车。她已经说了几百万次了。“如果我能做到就好了，巴迪。生活中得不到自己想要的东西已经够糟糕的了。但见鬼的是，让我火大的是无法给别人你希望他们拥有的东西。不过总有一天，我会的，巴迪。给你弄辆自行车。别问怎么弄的。可能是偷来的。”
Instead, I am fairly certain that she is building me a kite. The same as last year and the year before. The year before that we exchanged slingshots. All of which is fine by me, for we are champion kite flyers who study the wind like sailors. My friend, more accomplished than I, can get a kite aloft when there isn't enough breeze to carry clouds.
相反，我敢肯定她正在给我做一个风筝。和去年以及前年一样。在前年我们交换了弹弓。这对我来说都很好，因为我们是冠军级的风筝飞手，像水手一样研究风。我朋友比我更精通，即使没有足够的微风带动云朵，她也能让风筝飞起来。
Christmas Eve afternoon, we scrape together a nickel and go to the butcher's to buy Queenie's traditional gift, a good, gnawable beef bone. The bone, wrapped in funny paper, is placed high in the tree near the silver star. Queenie knows it's there. She squats at the foot of the tree, staring up in a trance of greed. When bedtime arrives, she refuses to budge. Her excitement is equalled by my own. I kick the covers and turn my pillow as though it were a scorching summer's night. Somewhere a rooster crows, falsely, for the sun is still on the other side of the world.
圣诞夜下午，我们凑了一个镍币，去屠夫那里买奎尼的传统礼物，一根好的、耐啃的牛肉骨头。骨头被包在滑稽报纸里，放在树顶银星旁。奎尼知道它在那儿。她蹲在树下，盯着上面，陷入了贪婪的恍惚。到了睡觉时间，她拒绝挪窝。她的兴奋和我一样。我踢开被子，翻转枕头，仿佛那是闷热的夏夜。某处一只公鸡虚假地打鸣了，因为太阳还在世界的另一边。
"Buddy, are you awake?"
“巴迪，你醒了吗？”
It is my friend, calling from her room, which is next to mine. And an instant later, she is sitting on my bed, holding a candle.
是我朋友，从我隔壁的房间打来的。片刻之后，她坐在我的床上，拿着一支蜡烛。
"Well, I can't sleep a hoot," she declares. "My mind's jumping like a jack rabbit. Buddy, do you think Mrs. Roosevelt will serve our cake at dinner?" We huddle in the bed, and she squeezes my hand I love you.
“好吧，我一点也睡不着，”她宣布。“我的大脑跳得像只野兔。巴迪，你觉得罗斯福夫人会在晚宴上端出我们的蛋糕吗？” 我们缩在床上，她握住我的手，我爱你。
"Seems like your hand used to be so much smaller. I guess I hate to see you grow up. When you're grown up, will we still be friends?" I say always. "But I feel so bad, Buddy. I wanted so bad to give you a bike. I tried to sell my cameo Papa gave me. Buddy," she hesitates, as though embarrassed, "I made you another kite." Then I confess that I made her one, too, and we laugh. The candle burns too short to hold. Out it goes, exposing the starlight. The star spinning at the window like a visible caroling that slowly, slowly, daybreak silences. Possibly, we doze.
“看起来你的手以前小得多。我想我讨厌看着你长大。当你长大后，我们还会是朋友吗？” 我说永远。 “但我感觉很不好，巴迪。我太想送你一辆自行车了。我试图卖掉爸爸给我的浮雕饰针。巴迪，”她犹豫着，好像很尴尬，“我给你做了另一个风筝。” 然后我承认我也给她做了一个，我们都笑了。蜡烛烧得太短，拿不住了。它熄灭了，露出了星光。那颗星星在窗前旋转，像一种可见的歌声，慢慢地、慢慢地被黎明静默。可能，我们打了个盹儿。
But the beginnings of dawn splash us like cold water. We're up, wide-eyed and wandering, while we wait for others to awaken. Quite deliberately, my friend drops a kettle on the kitchen floor. I tap dance in front of closed doors. One by one, the household emerges, looking as though they'd like to kill us both, but it's Christmas, so they can't. First, a gorgeous breakfast, just everything you can imagine, from flapjacks and fried squirrel to hominy grits and honey in the comb, which puts everyone in a good humor, except my friend and I. Frankly, we're so impatient to get at the presents we can't eat a mouthful.
但黎明的曙光像冷水一样溅在我们身上。我们起床了，睁大眼睛游荡，等待其他人苏醒。我朋友故意把水壶摔在厨房地板上。我在紧闭的门前跳踢踏舞。家人们一个接一个地出来，看起来恨不得杀了我们俩，但今天是圣诞节，所以他们不能。首先是一顿豪华早餐，你能想象到的一切，从煎饼、炸松鼠到玉米糁和蜂巢蜜，这让大家心情都变好了，除了我和我朋友。坦白说，我们急着拆礼物，一口都吃不下。
Well, I'm disappointed. Who wouldn't be? With socks, a Sunday school shirt, some handkerchiefs, a hand-me-down sweater, and a year's subscription to a religious magazine for children, The Little Shepherd. It makes me boil, it really does.
好吧，我很失望。谁会不失望呢？袜子、一件主日学衬衫、一些手帕、一件传下来的旧毛衣，还有一份一年期的儿童宗教杂志《小牧人》（The Little Shepherd）订阅。这让我火冒三丈，真的。
"Buddy, the wind is blowing."
“巴迪，风在刮。”
The wind is blowing, and nothing will do till we've run to a pasture below the house, where Queenie has scooted to bury her bone. And where, a winter hence, Queenie will be buried too. There, plunging through the healthy waist-high grass, we unreel our kites, feel them twitching at the string like sky fish as they swim into the wind. Satisfied, sun warmed, we sprawl in the grass and peel Satsumas and watch our kites cavort. Soon I forget the socks and hand-me-down sweater. I'm as happy as if we had already won the $50,000 grand prize in that coffee naming contest.
风在刮，在跑到屋下方的牧场之前，什么都做不了，奎尼在那儿匆忙地埋她的骨头。而一年后的冬天，奎尼也会被埋在那里。在那里，在齐腰高的健康草丛中穿行，我们放开风筝线，感觉它们在风中像天空中的鱼一样在指尖颤动。心满意足、沐浴在阳光下，我们趴在草地上剥着温州蜜柑，看着我们的风筝嬉戏。很快我忘记了袜子和那件传下来的旧毛衣。我快乐得仿佛我们已经赢得了那个咖啡命名大赛的5万美元大奖。
"My, how foolish I am," my friend cries, suddenly alert, like a woman remembering too late she has biscuits in the oven. "You know what I've always thought," she asked, in a tone of discovery, and not smiling at me but a point beyond. "I've always thought a body would have to be sick and dying before they saw the Lord. And I imagine that when he came, it would be like looking at the Baptist window. Pretty as colored glass with the sun pouring through. Such a shine, you don't know it's getting dark. And it's been a comfort to think of that shine taking away all the spooky feeling. But I'll wager it never happens. I'll wager, at the very end, a body realizes the Lord has already shown Himself. That things as they are--" Her hand circles in a gesture that gathers clouds, and kites, and grass, and Queenie pawing earth over her bone-- "Just what they've always seen was seeing Him. As for me, I could leave the world with today in my eyes."
“天哪，我多傻啊，”我朋友突然警觉地大叫，像个太晚想起烤箱里还有饼干的女人。“你知道我一直想什么吗，”她用一种发现的语气问道，不是看着我微笑，而是看着远处的一点。“我一直认为一个人必须在生病临死前才能见到上帝。我想象他到来时，就像看着浸信会窗户一样。像透过阳光照射的彩色玻璃一样漂亮。那样的光辉，你都不知道天快黑了。想到那光辉带走所有恐惧的感觉是一种安慰。但我敢打赌，那永远不会发生。我敢打赌，最后，一个人会意识到上帝已经展现了自己。事情本来的样子——” 她的手画了个圈，把云朵、风筝、草地，还有奎尼在骨头上刨土的样子都囊括了进去—— “他们一直以来所见的就是见证他。至于我，如果眼里能有今天这番景色，我就可以离开这个世界了。”
This is our last Christmas together. Life separates us. Those who know best decide that I belong in a military school. And so follows a miserable succession of bugle blowing prisons, grim, revelry-ridden summer camps. I have a new home, too, but it doesn't count. Home is where my friend is, and there I never go. And there she remains, puttering around the kitchen, alone with Queenie, then alone. "Buddy dear," she writes in her wild, hard to read script, "yesterday, Jim Macy's horse kicked Queenie bad. Be thankful she didn't feel much. I wrapped her in a fine linen sheet and rode her in the buggy down to Simpson's pasture, where she can be with all her bones."
这是我们在一起的最后一个圣诞节。生活将我们分开。那些自以为是的人决定我应该去军校。随后便是一连串悲惨的吹号监狱、阴冷、充满喧嚣的夏令营。我也有了新家，但这不算数。家是我朋友所在的地方，但我从不去那里。她留在那儿，在厨房里忙碌，独自和奎尼在一起，然后是独自一人。 “亲爱的巴迪，”她用狂乱、难辨的笔迹写道，“昨天，吉姆·梅西（Jim Macy）的马把奎尼踢得很厉害。庆幸她没感到太痛苦吧。我用一块精细的亚麻布把她包起来，用马车把她拉到辛普森（Simpson）的牧场，在那里她可以和她所有的骨头在一起了。”
For a few Novembers, she continues to bake her fruitcakes single handed. Not as many, but some. And of course, she always sends me the best of the batch. But gradually in her letters, she tends to confuse me with her other friend. The Buddy who died in the 1880s. A morning arrives in November, a leafless, birdless, coming of winter morning, when she can not rouse herself to exclaim, "Oh my, it's fruitcake weather." And when that happens, I know it. A message saying so merely confirms a piece of news some secret vein had already received, severing from me an irreplaceable part of myself, letting it loose like a kite on a broken string. That is why, walking across the school campus on this particular December morning, I keep searching the sky, as if I expected to see, rather like hearts, a lost pair of kites hurrying toward heaven.
又过了几个11月，她继续独自烘焙水果蛋糕。没那么多，但还是有一些。当然，她总是把最好的一批寄给我。但渐渐地在她的信中，她倾向于把我弄混成她的另一个朋友。那个在19世纪80年代去世的巴迪。一个11月的清晨到来，一个无叶、无鸟、即将来临的冬日早晨，她无法再勉强自己感叹“噢，天哪，这是做水果蛋糕的天气。” 而当那发生时，我感觉到了。一条这么说的消息只是证实了一个秘密脉络早已接收到的消息，切断了我身上不可替代的一部分，像断了线的风筝一样让它自由飞走。这就是为什么，在那个特别的12月早晨走在学校校园时，我一直搜寻着天空，仿佛我期待着看到，如同心灵般，一对迷失的风筝正匆匆奔向天堂。
Truman Capote, recorded in 1959. "A Christmas Memory" was broadcast with permission of the Truman Capote Literary Trust. Alan U. Schwartz, trustee. This version of the story was abridged for radio. Coming up, more proof that the perfect gift, like the perfect crime, is an elusive thing. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
杜鲁门·卡波特，1959年录制。《圣诞记忆》经杜鲁门·卡波特文学信托授权播出。艾伦·U·施瓦茨（Alan U. Schwartz），受托人。此版本故事已为广播删节。接下来，更多证明“完美礼物就像完美犯罪一样，是难以捉摸的东西”的证据。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. It's our guide to holiday gift giving in which we guarantee you will find no practical advice for your last minute shopping. Instead, we have stories of holiday presents. We're at act three of our show. Act Three, Secret Santa. Caitlin Shetterly has this story about one gift leading to another, leading to another, leading to another, and then stopping.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。这是我们的节日送礼指南，我们保证你在这里找不到任何实用的最后一分钟购物建议。相反，我们有关于节日礼物的故事。我们节目进入第三幕。第三幕，《秘密圣诞老人》。凯特琳·谢特利（Caitlin Shetterly）讲述了这个关于一份礼物引出另一份礼物，再引出另一份，最后停下来的故事。
I grew up in a small town called Surry on the coast of down-east Maine. At Christmas, most everyone in our town bought their trees at Jordan's Tree Farm. $5 per tree, cut at your own risk. Thinking back, it seems funny to me now, since after all, this is rural Maine, the pine tree state. And you'd think everyone could cut their own trees on their own land. And it's not like the trees at the Jordan farm were so special. Pretty much everyone called them Charlie Brown trees. People came because of Robert Jordan. They were loyal to him, and they figured he could use the money.
我在缅因州东部海岸一个叫萨里（Surry）的小镇长大。圣诞节时，镇上几乎每个人都在乔丹树场（Jordan's Tree Farm）买树。每棵树5美元，自己动手砍。回想起来，现在觉得很有趣，毕竟这是缅因州乡村，松树之州。你可能会觉得每个人都可以在自己的土地上砍树。而且乔丹树场的树也没什么特别的。几乎每个人都管它们叫“查理·布朗（Charlie Brown）”树。人们来是因为罗伯特·乔丹（Robert Jordan）。他们对他很忠诚，而且他们觉得他可能需要那笔钱。
Every year the drill was the same. You'd get out of your car with your family, trudge for what seemed like miles in sub-zero wind, searching for the perfect tree. Drag your prize back through the snow, and then, finally, you'd go find Robert. This was one of the only times of year most of us saw Robert. He seemed to live an entirely reclusive life in his ramshackle house, perched above the road and bordering the thick trees that fanned out behind his barn.
每年流程都一样。你和家人下车，在零下的风中走上几英里，寻找完美的树。把你的战利品拖回雪地里，最后，你会去找罗伯特。这是我们一年中见到罗伯特的少数几次机会之一。他似乎在那个破旧的房子里过着完全与世隔绝的生活，房子坐落在路上方，毗邻他谷仓后方展开的茂密树林。
Many of us know someone like Robert, our own Boo Radley, a poor old man who has lived with his parents his entire life until one, and then the other, died. Here is what we knew about Robert from these short, yearly transactions. He had a very strange voice. He wore Coke bottle glasses, an orange hunting cap, and in my memory, a red and black Buffalo plaid jacket. But somehow Ron Hamilton and his wife Brenda came to know Robert better than most people did. Here's Ron.
我们很多人都认识像罗伯特这样的人，我们自己的“布·拉德利”（Boo Radley，《杀死一只知更鸟》中的角色），一个可怜的老人，和父母住了一辈子，直到一个接着一个去世。这是我们从每年这些简短交易中了解到的罗伯特。他声音很奇怪。他戴着可乐瓶底厚的眼镜，戴着橘色的狩猎帽，在我的记忆中，还穿着红黑格子的法兰绒外套。但不知何故，罗恩·汉密尔顿（Ron Hamilton）和他的妻子布伦达（Brenda）比大多数人更了解罗伯特。这是罗恩。
A lot of people thought Robert was retarded because his father was hard of hearing, and he kind of talked like this. You know. I kind of mimic him a little bit, but every now and then he'd say something like, "Well, how are you today?" And I'd say, "Pretty good, Robert." "Well, what are we going to do today?" And it kind of reminded me of, Katharine Hepburn is it, that's got that same kind of broken spot in her voice. But he never knew he done that until later in life. Because his father was almost deaf, Clyde. He'd have to look at you and went, "What? What?" And Robert would belt it right out.
很多人以为罗伯特智障，因为他父亲听力不好，他说话有点像这样。你知道的。我模仿一下他，但他偶尔会说，“嗯，你今天好吗？” 我会说，“挺好，罗伯特。” “嗯，我们今天要干什么？” 这让我想起了凯瑟琳·赫本（Katharine Hepburn），她声音里也有那种破碎的感觉。但他直到晚年都不知道自己有这种习惯。因为他父亲克莱德（Clyde）几乎是聋子。他必须看着你说，“什么？什么？” 然后罗伯特就会大声喊出来。
The farmhouse and the Jordan's lifestyle on the farm was primitive. The house had no hot water. Clyde and Robert ate canned cold beans for breakfast. Their porch was overflowing with junk and cats and smelled like cat food and urine. Robert slept in a chair in the living room, and Clyde slept on a small cot next to the wood stove in the kitchen. Robert's mother Bessie had passed away in 1987, in one of the small bedrooms upstairs. Since then the two men were on their own.
农场里的农舍和乔丹一家的生活方式很原始。房子没有热水。克莱德和罗伯特早餐吃罐装凉豆子。他们的门廊堆满了垃圾和猫，闻起来像猫粮和尿。罗伯特睡在客厅的椅子上，克莱德睡在厨房炉子旁的小床上。罗伯特的母亲贝西（Bessie）于1987年在楼上的小卧室去世。从那以后，这两个男人就靠自己了。
About 15 years ago, Ronnie Hamilton and his wife Brenda met Robert and Clyde. Brenda was making and selling Christmas wreaths. And when Robert saw them, he invited the Hamilton's first to get brush from the farm to make their wreaths and later, to sell them at the farm. They ended up spending a lot of time together. Despite the Christmas tree farm, Robert and his late mother were Jehovah's Witnesses. And so the family didn't actually celebrate Christmas. But Ronnie and Brenda wanted to include them into their holiday. One day Ron noticed Clyde was wearing two different boots and that on the coldest days, they weren't keeping his feet warm.
大约15年前，罗尼·汉密尔顿和妻子布伦达遇到了罗伯特和克莱德。布伦达当时在制作和销售圣诞花环。当罗伯特看到这些时，他邀请汉密尔顿一家先来农场采集刷子做花环，后来又让他们在农场卖。他们最终花了很多时间在一起。尽管有圣诞树农场，但罗伯特和已故母亲是耶和华见证人。所以他们家其实不庆祝圣诞节。但罗尼和布伦达想把他们纳入到自己的节日中。有一天，罗恩注意到克莱德穿着两只不同的靴子，而且在最冷的日子里，它们并不保暖。
So I went and bought him a pair of boots. And we bought Robert a pair of sneakers, because I knew Robert liked the ones that you didn't have to lace up, that just had the Velcro. Anyway, we got several little things in a Christmas stocking. Well, day before Christmas, I had come over and knocked on the door and I says, "Santa's here." And they had come in. And he says, "What did you do that for?" I said, "Because I want to." And I said, just because you like to do things for people. And I asked what did you do that for. And he says because he wanted to. So I kind of put it right back to him that way. He liked Christmas.
所以我买了双靴子给他。我们还给罗伯特买了双球鞋，因为我知道罗伯特喜欢那种不用系鞋带的，只有魔术贴的。不管怎样，我们在圣诞袜里装了好些小东西。圣诞节前一天，我敲门说：“圣诞老人来了。” 他们进来了。他说：“你做这个干什么？” 我说：“因为我想做。” 我说，只是因为你喜欢为别人做点事。我也问他你做那个干什么。他说因为他想做。所以我以同样的方式回敬他。他喜欢圣诞节。
After that first Christmas, Robert began exchanging gifts each year with Ron and Brenda. As Clyde got older and started to rely on Robert, Robert started to rely on the Hamiltons. Late one night, Clyde got so sick, Robert called Ron for help.
在那第一个圣诞节之后，罗伯特每年都开始和罗恩及布伦达交换礼物。随着克莱德变老并开始依赖罗伯特，罗伯特也开始依赖汉密尔顿一家。一天深夜，克莱德病得很重，罗伯特打电话向罗恩求助。
And he says, "Father's sick. Can you come get him?" This was like 11:30, 12 o'clock at night, and snowy and stuff. I went over and got him, picked him up, and put him in the truck, and took him to Blue Hill Hospital. Well, needless to say, he had cancer. And that went on for about a year. And finally, Robert's father was in the hospital real bad there. And Robert called me up. And he said, would you take me over to see Dad. I says, yeah. Went in and the doctor said, it's just a matter of time. And I said to Robert, if you want to say something to your father, you want to say it now.
他说，“爸爸病了。你能来接他吗？” 当时大约是深夜11:30、12点，而且在下雪什么的。我过去接了他，把他抱上卡车，带到了蓝山医院（Blue Hill Hospital）。不用说，他得了癌症。这持续了大约一年。最后，罗伯特的父亲在医院病得很重。罗伯特打电话给我。他说，你能带我去看看爸爸吗。我说，行。进去后医生说，只是时间问题了。我对罗伯特说，如果你想对你父亲说什么，现在就说吧。
We got a kick out of this, because we chuckled about it afterwards. He said, but I can't get him awake. I said, I can get him awake. He said, you can? And he said, how? And I said, you watch. And I said, Clyde, there's somebody in your Christmas trees. He opened up one eye. And he looked at me, and said, I'm not dead yet. I said to Robert, you want to say something to your father, you want to talk to him now. So they talked for a few minutes, then Clyde dozed off. And Robert called me the next morning and told me his father had died.
我们觉得这事很有趣，因为事后我们还为此窃笑。他说，但我叫不醒他。我说，我能叫醒他。他说，你能？我说，怎么叫？我说，你看着。我说，克莱德，有人在你的圣诞树里。他睁开了一只眼。他看着我，说，我还没死呢。我对罗伯特说，你想对你父亲说什么，现在就跟他谈吧。他们谈了几分钟，然后克莱德睡着了。罗伯特第二天早上打电话告诉我他父亲去世了。
Robert asked Ron to take care of the burial arrangements. So Ron dug the hole for Clyde's remains, gathered some friends, and said a few final words. Then Robert asked Ron if, when it came time, he would do the same for him. Ron said yes.
罗伯特请罗恩处理安葬事宜。所以罗恩为克莱德的遗骸挖了坑，召集了一些朋友，说了几句告别的话。然后罗伯特问罗恩，如果到时候，他能不能也为他做同样的事。罗恩说好。
Robert was 65 when his father died. He had struggled with diabetes for most of his life. He had had heart problems. And he was in and out of the hospital. He stayed with Ron and Brenda for a couple of months in the winter of 2000 because he couldn't take care of himself. He loved the hot showers and the television with a remote control they had at their house. Eventually, Robert went back to the farm and to his independence. He started walking four miles a day and lost some weight. Then in mid April of 2001, Ron went over early one morning to pick Robert up to take him into town. He found Robert lying on the floor. He was dead.
父亲去世时，罗伯特65岁。他一生都在与糖尿病作斗争。他有心脏问题。进进出出医院。2000年冬天，他因为无法自理，在罗恩和布伦达家住了几个月。他喜欢他们家热水淋浴和带遥控器的电视。最终，罗伯特回到了农场，回到了他独立的生活。他开始每天走四英里，减掉了一些体重。然后2001年4月中旬，罗恩一天清早过去想带罗伯特进城。他发现罗伯特躺在地板上。他死了。
Ron kept his promise to Robert, and held a small ceremony on a sunny April afternoon. He scattered Robert's ashes out back at the farm among the Christmas trees. A few days later, the Hamiltons were contacted to come to a reading of Robert's will, along with representatives from five local nonprofit organizations. As the lawyers started to read out the will, people were stunned. It turns out Robert Jordan was a millionaire. Robert had inherited a couple hundred thousand in AT&T stock from three neighbors. Wealthy sisters who had a summer place across the road.
罗恩信守了对罗伯特的承诺，在一个阳光明媚的四月午后举行了一个小型仪式。他把罗伯特的骨灰洒在了农场后方的圣诞树丛中。几天后，汉密尔顿一家接到通知去参加罗伯特的遗嘱宣读，同时还有五家当地非营利组织的代表。当律师开始宣读遗嘱时，人们惊呆了。原来罗伯特·乔丹是个百万富翁。罗伯特从三位邻居那里继承了几十万的AT&T股票。那是三位住在路对面有避暑别墅的富有姐妹。
When Robert was growing up, he had mowed lawns and run errands for the sisters. And when they got older he had taken care of them. When the last sister, Betty, died in 1984, she left Robert the stock and her house. Robert sold the house, and as for the stock, his timing was perfect. It boomed. Robert had divided up his money between local organizations he was interested in or had been kind to him. But the largest gift was left to Ron and Brenda Hamilton. Robert Jordan had left them the farm.
罗伯特小时候曾为这几位姐妹割草和跑腿。她们老了以后，他也照顾过她们。当最后一个姐妹贝蒂（Betty）在1984年去世时，她把股票和房子留给了罗伯特。罗伯特卖掉了房子，至于股票，他的时机非常完美。它暴涨了。罗伯特把他的一些钱分给了他感兴趣或曾对他友好的当地组织。但最大的遗产留给了罗恩和布伦达·汉密尔顿。罗伯特·乔丹把农场留给了他们。
Well, I was flabbergasted. I couldn't believe it. To this day I don't believe it, because I didn't look for nothing from nobody. We were so excited. So we packed up our stuff, and started cleaning on the farm, and fixed the farm up a little bit, and the barn and stuff. Moved in, and it was just a lovely spot.
嗯，我目瞪口呆。我不敢相信。直到今天我都不敢相信，因为我没有图任何人的东西。我们太兴奋了。所以我们收拾东西，开始打扫农场，把农场、谷仓之类的修整了一下。搬了进去，那真是个可爱的地方。
The tree farm Robert left to Ronnie and Brenda sits on top of a hill looking over Route 172. It has 66 acres of trees and a natural spring. The house is white, and from the road it looks bigger than it really is. The only sink was in the kitchen. And the house had no heat besides the wood stove. In August of 2001, Ronnie and Brenda moved in. They were excited, not daunted, by the task that lay ahead of them.
罗伯特留给罗尼和布伦达的树场坐落在俯瞰172号公路的山顶上。它有66英亩的树林和一个天然泉水。房子是白色的，从路上看比实际看起来大。唯一的洗碗槽在厨房里。除了木炉子，房子没有暖气。2001年8月，罗尼和布伦达搬了进去。他们对面前的任务感到兴奋，而不是畏缩。
A year later, I went to visit Ronnie and Brenda. It was the first time I'd actually been able to walk onto the porch. The clutter was gone, a small gray kitten lay curled on a couch, and three dogs met me at the door. It was as if Ronnie and Brenda's world had opened up. Ron told me that Robert's gift had completely changed his life.
一年后，我去探望罗尼和布伦达。这是我第一次真正走到门廊上。杂乱不见了，一只小灰猫蜷缩在沙发上，三条狗在门口迎接我。就好像罗尼和布伦达的世界敞开了。罗恩告诉我，罗伯特的礼物彻底改变了他的生活。
I don't have so much tension on me, you know, thinking that, what am I going to do. Now I know what I'm going to do. I'm going to work on these Christmas trees most of the rest of my life and enjoy it like he did.
我没那么大压力了，你知道，总是想，我该怎么办。现在我知道我要做什么了。我余生大部分时间都要在这打理圣诞树，并像他一样享受它。
When I left that night, Ron walked me to my car.
那天晚上我离开时，罗恩送我到车边。
That's great. Thank you so much.
太好了。非常感谢。
Well, thank you dear.
嗯，谢谢你，亲爱的。
I think I'll come back at Christmas.
我想我圣诞节会再来。
OK. Are you going to get your tree?
好的。你要来挑你的树吗？
Yeah, I'm definitely going to come get a tree. For sure. Thank you.
对，我肯定会来挑棵树。一定。谢谢。
Thank you dear.
谢谢你，亲爱的。
Test, test.
测试，测试。
Four months later, it's Christmas Eve, and I'm back at the tree farm.
四个月后，到了圣诞夜，我又回到了树场。
Hi.
嗨。
Come on in, dear.
进来吧，亲爱的。
How are you? Boy, your house looks great. It's coming together. Oh, look at the tree.
你好吗？天哪，你们的房子看起来棒极了。正在完善中。噢，看那棵树。
Is it going well, though, living here? Are you feeling good about it?
在这里生活还好吗？感觉好吗？
I had nothing but trouble over here all summer long.
整个夏天我在这边都没少遇到麻烦。
Tell me why.
告诉我为什么。
Some people broke into my pickup truck and had taken my pills. And come in here.
有人闯进我的皮卡车偷了我的药。然后进到这里。
After the Hamiltons moved in, things got complicated. The house and the barn needed a lot of work. And the Hamiltons needed money they didn't have to do that work. Tending to 66 acres of farm that stretched over a mile back from the road was hard for Ron. One day he fell while surveying the land, and he pulled the muscles and tendons in his neck. Ron went to the hospital and was given painkillers, which he brought home. And a day later, some kids broke into his truck and stole his medicine. Then, believe it or not, things took a turn for the worse.
汉密尔顿一家搬进来后，事情变得复杂了。房子和谷仓需要大量翻修。汉密尔顿一家需要他们没有的钱来做那些工作。打理从路边向后延伸一英里的66英亩农场对罗恩来说很困难。有一天他在勘测土地时摔倒了，拉伤了脖子的肌肉和肌腱。罗恩去了医院，得到了一些止痛药，带回了家。一天后，一些孩子闯进他的车偷了他的药。然后，你信不信，情况变得更糟了。
They tried to arrest me and charge me with growing marijuana, which wasn't mine.
他们试图逮捕我并控告我种植大麻，那根本不是我的。
Where was the marijuana?
大麻在哪？
Somebody had planted it out back in the Christmas trees, two or three different plots of it.
有人在后方的圣诞树林里种了，两三块地。
The police came?
警察来了？
Oh, helicopter, the whole nine yards.
噢，直升机，全套阵仗。
Who planted that, do you think?
你觉得是谁种的？
I don't know. I have no idea.
不知道。我毫无头绪。
Ron had to hire a lawyer to prove that the plants weren't his, putting him into even more debt. And on top of all that, Ron had a heart attack. This all happened within four months. Finally, Ron and Brenda decided to sell the farm. With the money they got from selling the farm to their neighbor, Bill [? Kidue, ?] they built a small, one level house on seven acres of land, over closer to Ellsworth on a busy road. Ron has been back a few times to cut brush for Brenda's wreaths. But when I asked Ronnie to take me back to the farm, he refused, saying it was just too painful.
罗恩不得不请律师证明那些植物不是他的，这让他背上了更多的债。而且最重要的是，罗恩心脏病发作了。这一切都发生在四个月之内。最终，罗恩和布伦达决定卖掉农场。用卖给邻居比尔·基杜（Bill Kidue）农场的钱，他们在埃尔斯沃斯（Ellsworth）附近的一条繁忙公路旁，在七英亩土地上建了一栋单层小房子。罗恩回来过几次帮布伦达修剪做花环用的灌木。但当我让罗尼带我回农场时，他拒绝了，说那太痛苦了。
Well yeah, it kind of bothers you.
嗯，是的，确实让人心烦。
Why does it bother you?
为什么让你心烦？
I don't know. Just thinking it was mine. I wish that I could have kept it.
不知道。一想到它本来是我的。我真希望我能留住它。
This is Brenda, Ronnie's wife.
这是布伦达，罗尼的妻子。
It was nice in the summer. You'd go out and sit on the porch there. And we'd watch traffic go by. We'd sit there until it was real dark because it was all screened in. It was nice out there. Nice porch.
夏天的时候很美好。你会出去坐在门廊上。看着车流经过。我们会一直坐到天完全黑下来，因为那儿有纱窗遮挡。外面很不错。很好的门廊。
When we first moved to the farm it was just like we remarried. Everything was just cozy, and the colder it got, the more we snuggled. It was different. It was better. It was more-- it's a country life. Every morning she'd get up and have a coffee pot going, and take a cup of coffee with her and the dogs. And she'd walk out back. And she'd say, well, we've got several deer crossings out there, or you ought to see the turkey tracks, or there's coyote droppings out there.
我们刚搬到农场时，感觉就像又结了一次婚。一切都很舒适，越冷我们贴得越紧。不一样了。更好。更……那是一种乡村生活。每天早晨她都会起床，煮上一壶咖啡，拿着一杯咖啡和狗一起走出去。她会走到后方。然后她说，嗯，我们外面有几条鹿的足迹，或者你该看看火鸡的脚印，或者外面有郊狼的粪便。
And we had visions. We talked about, we wanted to take this little pond, and it would make a beautiful ice skating pond. We thought, well, we could have the kids come over. And they could ice skate over there, get them off the streets, you know. And then eventually, that we could have a horse and a sleigh and give sleigh rides over there. But it didn't turn out that way. But we dreamt of it. Didn't we, dear?
我们有憧憬。我们谈过，想利用这个小池塘，那会成为一个美丽的滑冰池。我们想，嗯，我们可以让孩子们过来。他们可以在那儿滑冰，让他们远离街头，你知道的。然后最终，我们可以养一匹马，买一辆雪橇，在那儿提供滑雪服务。但结果并非如此。但我们梦想过。不是吗，亲爱的？
Later, Brenda tells me that she doesn't like the new house they've built. She says it doesn't feel like a home and she doesn't want to decorate for Christmas this year. Their whole idea of Christmas is still tied up in the dreams they had for the farm. In the Dylan Thomas poem, "A Child's Christmas in Wales," there is a point toward the end where the narrator and his childhood friends go caroling in the dark. They walk up a long driveway to a large house, and although they are afraid, they soldier on. And as they begin to sing, a voice joins theirs from behind the dark door. Thomas writes, "A small, dry voice, like the voice of someone who has not spoken for a long time joined our singing. A small, dry, eggshell voice from the other side of the door. A small dry voice through the keyhole." The boys run, and never finish their song.
后来，布伦达告诉我她不喜欢他们建的新房子。她说这感觉不像个家，她今年不想装饰圣诞节了。他们整个圣诞节的构想仍然与他们对农场的梦想纠缠在一起。在迪伦·托马斯（Dylan Thomas）的诗《童年的圣诞节在威尔士》（A Child's Christmas in Wales）中，结尾处叙述者和儿时好友在黑暗中唱颂歌。他们沿着长长的车道走向一栋大房子，虽然他们很害怕，但还是继续前行。当他们开始唱歌时，一个声音从黑暗的门后加入了他们的歌唱。托马斯写道：“一个干燥的小声音，像很久没说过话的人的声音，加入了我们的歌唱。一个来自门后的干瘪蛋壳般的声音。透过锁孔的一个干燥小声音。” 男孩们跑了，再也没唱完那首歌。
When I was little, I used to go with the Surry Elementary School to sing carols outside Robert Jordan's house. And I always confused the voice in the poem with the real life Robert Jordan, someone isolated, someone people don't stick around for. But that wasn't really who he was. He reached out to people. He helped out his neighbors across the street without asking for anything. In return, they made him a millionaire. And when Ronnie and Brenda helped him without asking for anything, in return, he gave them the farm.
我小的时候，经常和萨里小学（Surry Elementary School）的同学去罗伯特·乔丹家门口唱颂歌。我总是把诗里的声音和现实生活中的罗伯特·乔丹混在一起，那个孤立的、人们不愿久留的人。但那并不是真正的他。他主动接近人们。他帮助街对面的邻居，却从不求回报。作为回报，他们让他成了百万富翁。当罗尼和布伦达不求回报地帮助他时，作为回报，他把农场留给了他们。
So much of his life was about a kind of selfless giving. And sometimes it didn't work out, sure. Ronnie and Brenda are definitely going to miss the farm this Christmas. But Ron still has hope for the holidays. He thinks their house won't feel so much like a motel once they get the tree up, put some lights outside, and have some family over. Already, Brenda has nearly sold all her wreaths. And when I called this week, Ron was already ahead of the game. His shopping is all done. And he was busy wrapping presents for his wife.
他的一生很大程度上是关于一种无私的给予。有时它没能如愿，当然。罗尼和布伦达这个圣诞节肯定会想念农场。但罗恩对节日仍然抱有希望。他认为只要他们挂上树、在外面点亮灯光并请些家人过来，他们的家就不会感觉那么像汽车旅馆了。布伦达的花环几乎都卖光了。当我这周打电话时，罗恩已经抢占了先机。他的购物都完成了。他正在忙着为妻子包装礼物。
Caitlin Shetterly is the artistic director of the Winter Harbor Theater Company in Portland, Maine.
凯特琳·谢特利是缅因州波特兰冬港剧团（Winter Harbor Theater Company）的艺术总监。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Golombisky and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, and Starlee Kine. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Kelsey Dilts.
嗯，我们的节目今天由简·戈隆比斯基（Jane Golombisky）和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）和斯塔莉·基恩（Starlee Kine）参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和凯尔西·迪尔茨（Kelsey Dilts）提供了制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
You know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, best-selling books, even the New York Times, all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道你可以从audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。 《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, or as he likes to be known--
WBEZ的管理由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）监督，或者他喜欢被称为——
[SINGING - "OUR LORD EMMANUEL"]
[演唱 - 《我们的主以马内利》]
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。